how you doing dude good to see you nice
to see you uh what t-shirt did you wear
for me
i got orange cassidy of all elite
wrestling
there yeah i have to move
so are you watching heels right now
i am funny story
i got a copy of heels three years ago
back when it was like doing pilot season
um in like 2019 or something and i sent
it to cody rhodes and said
i think you should star in this show
and then covet and all these things
happen and i didn't know what happened
to it now it's
they shot it and it's on tv i'm i just
watched the first two episodes it's been
it's been fun to watch another wrestling
show i i was heartbroken when netflix
uh kicked kicked their uh glow show to
the curb i really loved that show
i i was hoping they were gonna get their
their last season i was very
disappointed that they pulled it
me too hopefully heels will satiate that
a little bit
jumping into why i get to talk to you
today is this one of these pro i'm
curious
um you are can be very funny and i'm
curious when you are stepping on set for
something like this how much are you
are the directors asking you to sort of
add to your character and how much do
you feel sort of obligated to just
what's on the
it page you know i don't get to do
comedy well i shouldn't say that i
probably do have drama house comedy at
this point but
when i do comedy you know i always
consider what what the project is so
back when i did cobra kai for season two
i had a million alt lines and ad-libs
and improvs to put in
but that show has a million characters
so you can't elongate things as much
because it has to be succinct in their
world that they've created
um so yeah with something like cobra kai
you only get maybe a couple improv lines
a season
but uh with queen pins aaron and gita
really trusted me
they knew i had an improvisational
background
and uh and of course vince van is like
an improv icon
um
so yeah it was the perfect scenario
where we could actually play and bring a
lot to the character and
get some outlines in and play around
with trying to make each other laugh and
the voice you know
i was basically just trying to rip off
dennis farina the late great dennis
farina
and i thought wouldn't it be fun to just
slap a chicago accent
on the character because the character's
so curmudgeon he's such a curmudgeon and
uh
i thought that voice would kind of age
him up even though he's like probably 35
years old you know
one of one of the things about this
movie that i think everyone can sort of
relate to coupons and wanting to get the
best deal i think that's one of the the
like it's one of the reasons i think
people are going to watch this because
people everyone wants to get a great
deal can you sort of talk about like
what what you enjoyed about the script
or the coupon aspect of the film
well you know steve i love specificity
there was a movie that came out about
eight years ago
uh called in a world
and i love that movie so much my buddy
lake of course famously wrote correct
and started it but
but that movie was so specific the world
of voice over
and you know a female lead in a comedy
which doesn't happen enough so i feel
like
this was another one of those movies
that had great specificity
and you know what what is the american
dream for the the couponing type
and and what does that look like and i
think kristin and kirby really
beautifully brought that to life the
screenplay really brought it to life and
and at the end of the day this is a
movie i would go see with like my
siblings or my family like it's a movie
that i think you should definitely go
see with multiple people
uh not just like i'm looking at box
office receipts i just mean like
at the end of the day you gotta laugh
with people especially in
the dark time our nation is in right now
so
hopefully people get that out of queen
pins that was our intent when we made it
yeah i had a blast watching but uh
anyway i gotta stop they're gonna throw
me out so i'm just gonna say congrats on
all your success recently i wish you
nothing but the best
dude it's always a pleasure to talk to
you man i hope you're doing well you i
am um you too man have a great day